>>> BREAKING NEWS.
NOTIFY JUST THE LAST HOUR, THE
SCHOOL BOARD IN BROWARD COUNTY,
FLORIDA, THE STATE'S SECOND
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT, VOTED
TO KEEP ITS MASK MANDATE,
DEFYING AN ORDER FROM REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS.
HE THREATENED TO WITHHOLD
BROWARD STATE FUNDING AS WELL AS
TWO MORE COUNTIES.
CNN'S LEYLA SANTIAGO REPORTS
FROM ONE OF THOSE COUNTIES WHICH
STARTED SCHOOL TODAY.
>> Reporter: IT MAKES YOU PAUSE,
IT DOES MAKE YOU PAUSE, BUT OUR
GOAL IS THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
OUR STUDENTS AND OUR STAFF.
>> Reporter: SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
TINA SAYS SHE'S WILLING TO RISK
HER SALARY TO SPARE THE STUDENTS
OF ALACHUA COUNTY FROM RISKING
THEIR HEALTH.
AS KIDS STEP INTO THE CLASSROOM
FOR THE FIRST DAY OF SCHOOL,
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS IS
THREATENING TO WITHHOLD SALARIES
FROM SUPERINTENDENTS OR SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS WHO ARE MANDATING
T
MASKS.
>> THE PARTY THAT EMPHASIZES
LOCAL CONTROL AND HAS COMPLETELY
REMOVED THE DECISIONMAKING
AUTHORITY FROM OUR OWN ELECTED
OFFICIALS HERE.
>> Reporter: IN ALACHUA COUNTY
SCHOOLS, STUDENTS ARE REQUIRED
TO WEAR A MASK FOR THE FIRST TWO
WEEKS UNLESS THEY PROVIDE A
DOCTOR'S NOTE.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE SAYS THOSE
COUNTIES ARE NOT COMPLYING WITH
HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER SAYING, IN
PART, WHEN DISTRICTS ENACT
POLICIES THAT REQUIRE A DOCTOR'S
NOTE, THEY ARE NOT GIVING ALL
PARENT A FREE CHOICE.
BUT SOME SCHOOLS FEEL THEY ARE
NOT GETTING A CHOICE.
>> IF WE CHOSE TO NOT DO THAT
BECAUSE OF MONEY OR POLITICS,
THEN WE WOULDN'T BE ADVOCATING
FOR THE BEST INTEREST AND SAFETY
OF OUR STUDENTS.
AND THAT IS WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR.
>> Reporter: AT HOWARD BISHOP
MIDDLE SCHOOL, TEACHERS TOLD US
THE FIRST DAY OF SCHOOL BROUGHT
EXCITEMENT, BUT ALSO A SENSE OF
APPREHENSION AND UNCERTAINTY
OVER THE MASK CONTROVERSY AND A
RISE IN HOSPITALIZATIONS.
FLORIDA HAS A HOSPITALIZATION
RATE THAT IS MORE THAN TRIPLE
THE NATIONAL RATE.
AND THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS REPORTS THAT THE U.S.
HAD AN 84% INCREASE IN NEW
COVID-19 CASES AMONG CHILDREN
DURING THE LAST WEEK OF JULY.
YET, DeSANTIS IS HOLDING FIRM.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA, IT'S
TOTALLY REASONABLE FOR A PARENT
TO SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT, I'D
RATHER SEND MY KID TO SCHOOL
WITHOUT WEARING THE MASK.
>> Reporter: BUT THE DATA SHOWS
MASKS WORK.
THIS PRINCIPAL SAYS MASKS ARE
ONLY ONE OF THE MITIGATION
STRATEGIES THEY HAVE IN PLACE.
>> WE KNOW HOW TO CONTACT TRACE
AND WHO MIGHT'VE BEEN AROUND A
POSITIVE CASE.
>> Reporter: ARE YOU EXPECTING
THAT?
>> UM, I HATE TO SOUND LIKE A
PESSIMIST, BUT WE'RE GOING TO BE
PREPARED FOR THAT.
>> Reporter: ALACHUA COUNTY
SCHOOLS SAY THEY ARE SEEING AN
INCREASING NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES
TESTING POSITIVE.
TWO EMPLOYEES AND ONE STUDENT
RECENTLY DIED FROM COVID.
ON MONDAY THERE WERE 32 NEW
POSITIVE CASES AND 72 EMPLOYEES
WERE IN QUARANTINE, AND THE
SCHOOL YEAR HAS ONLY JUST BEGUN.
NOW, AMIDST A PANDEMIC AND
POLITICS.
AND JUST MOMENTS AGO, PRESIDENT
BIDEN CRITICIZED THE GOVERNOR'S
EFFORTS HERE IN FLORIDA TO
PROHIBIT ANY SORT OF MASK
MANDATE.
AND THE SCHOOL IS CALLING IT,
QUOTE, DISINGENUOUS WHEN ASKED
IF HE HAD ANY FEDERAL AUTHORITY
TO INTERVENE, BIDEN SAID HE'S
LOOKING INTO IT.
>> ALL RIGHT, LEYLA SANTIAGO,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND I WANT TO BRING IN THE CHAIR
OF THE ALACHUA COUNTY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS BOARD IN THE GAINESVILLE
AREA.
NICE TO SEE YOU.
TODAY WAS THE FIRST DAY OF
SCHOOL.
>> I'M GLAD.
TODAY WAS THE FIRST --
>> HOW'S IT BEEN GOING?
AND HAVE ANY PARENTS SO FAR USED
THE DOCTOR'S NOTE TO GET THEIR
CHILD OUT OF WEARING A MASK?
>> I DON'T HAVE A NUMBER ON
THAT, POSSIBLY TOMORROW AFTER
THEY HAVE A CHANCE TO LOOK AT
THE OPT-OUT FORMS THAT MAY HAVE
BEEN SUBMITTED TODAY.
BUT TODAY WAS THE VERY FIRST
DAY, IT'S AN EXCITING TIME IN
THE ALACHUA COUNTY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
>> WELL, CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
FIRST DAY OF SCHOOL TODAY.
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS DOES NOT AGREE
THAT A DOCTOR'S NOTE GIVES
PARENTS ENOUGH OF A CHOICE.
AND HE IS THREATENING TO
WITHHOLD YOUR SALARY.
ARE YOU WILLING TO GIVE UP YOUR
PAY OVER THIS FIGHT?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR OUR CHILDREN TO BE
SAFE AND HAVE WELL-BEING AS WELL
AS OUR STAFF.
AND SO I'M ALL IN IF HE WANTS TO
TAKE THE SALARY AWAY FROM US,
OUR BOARD MEMBERS AS WELL AS THE
SUPERINTENDENT, I FEEL EVEN MORE
EMPOWERED THAT I KNOW I'M DOING
SOMETHING CORRECT.
>> SO, WHAT HAPPENS IF A STUDENT
SHOWS UP TO SCHOOL WITHOUT A
MASK AND A NOTE?
IS THERE DISCIPLINARY ACTION IF
THAT HAPPENS?
>> NO.
THERE WILL BE NO DISCIPLINE:
WELL, I'M GOING TO SAY THERE
SHOULD NOT BE ANY DISCIPLINARY
ACTION EXCEPT THAT WE HAVE TWO
NURSES AT EACH SCHOOL SITE, AND
I'M SURE THAT THEY WILL TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CALL THE PARENT
TO SAY THE STUDENT IS OUT OF
COMPLIANCE, WE CAN DO ONE OR TWO
THINGS, GIVE A CALL TO A PARENT,
WE HAVE PLENTY OF MASKS ON
CAMPUSES.
SO IT'S NO PROBLEM HANDING A
STUDENT A MASK TO PUT ON.
>> SO, WHY NOT DO THEN WHAT
OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE DOING
AND ALLOW PARENTS TO OPT OUT OF
THE MASK MANDATE?
WHY IS THERE THIS EXTRA STEP OF
REQUIRING A DOCTOR'S NOTE?
>> WELL, OUR OPT-OUT POLICY WILL
REQUIRE, BECAUSE, AS YOU EXPECT,
ANY PARENT CAN SAY THEIR CHILD
HAS A SITUATION.
WE WANT IT TO BE THROUGH A
PHYSICIAN THAT IS STATING THAT,
WILL SIGN OFF ON THAT SO THAT WE
KNOW THAT THIS IS ABSOLUTELY THE
TRUTH.
>> OF COURSE ALL OF THIS COULD
BE ALLEVIATED IN LARGE PART IF
CHILDREN 12 AND YOUNGER COULD
GET A VACCINE.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO THE FDA
AS YOU WAIT FOR THE EMERGENCY
AUTHORIZATION PROCESS TO PLAY
OUT?
>> WELL, WE ARE HOPING THAT THEY
WILL CONTINUE TO ADAMANTLY PUSH
TO FIND WHATEVER THEY NEED SO
THAT THE FDA CAN APPROVE THE
VACCINE FOR CHILDREN YOUNGER
THAN 1